hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
both my brother max
the other host of this channel and i
have been using the iphone 12 pro max
for over a month and we now have a good
amount of experience with it
so in this video i want to share the top
10
problems that we've noticed after using
the 12 pro max for a month
and i'll give you some very interesting
conclusions and purchasing advice
at the end of this video now before i
begin i do want to mention that for max
his biggest concern was the larger size
of the pro max
and he was actually considering buying
the regular 12 pro
instead but because of the camera
differences
he went with the max model and as it
turns out
the camera was actually quite
disappointing so before i get into those
problems let's start with problem number
one first off
one of the biggest problems is the lack
of a 120 hertz display
since so many other premium flagship
phones
already have high refresh rate displays
even mid-range phones these days
have higher than 60hz refresh rates the
oneplus 7 pro was released almost two
years ago
at a 669 dollar price tag
and it comes with a 90 hertz display
it's embarrassing that we're about to
enter into 2021
and apple doesn't at least have a 90hz
display on their 1100 flagship iphone
so that's definitely a problem but
thankfully rumors are pointing to next
year's pro models
getting 120 hertz refresh rates now
getting into problem number two
it has to do with the new square sides
while we absolutely love them because
they make the phone feel
new unique and they help with grip in
the hand
there are definitely some problems with
the new sides first off they make the
iphone 12s look very
thick despite actually being thinner
this year because of those square edges
the pro max kind of digs into your hand
while you're using it one-handed
so you can't reach as far up on the
display as with the iphone 11s
and it's also less comfortable if you're
holding it in landscape mode
since it can dig into your pinky so it
can be pretty annoying if you're holding
it like that for an extended period of
time
on top of that the new flat sides show
fingerprints
much more easily than before this is a
b-roll shot of my iphone
without cleaning it off or intentionally
adding fingerprints
it's like this all the time so i've
noticed that i spend more
time than ever before trying to keep it
clean moving on to problem number three
it really sucks that we no longer get a
charger in the box
the missing headphones i don't really
care for because i usually leave them in
the box
but as for the charging brick i was
really excited to get one
and since the current bricks from apple
use usbc
i could have actually used it for
charging other usbc devices
so it sucks that apple will no longer be
shipping out any more charging bricks
and now let's finally get into the
cameras with problem number four
something unique this year is that the
telephoto lens on the 12 pro max
finally has a longer optical zoom range
2.5 times
instead of two times on the regular pro
this was actually one of the reasons
why max chose to get the max model
instead
however there are definitely multiple
problems with it
first off to make the longer zoom
possible the aperture
was downgraded from f 2.0 to f 2.2
which basically takes in less light
because of that
the quality of zoom shots is actually
worse
on the pro max which completely ruins
the point
of the longer telephoto zoom lens on top
of that
night mode telephoto shots take longer
because it needs more time to collect
light
compared to the regular pro and taking
it even further
more zoomed in shots are harder to
stabilize
also adding to the time it takes to take
a night mode shot
i also feel like telephoto portrait
shots are less convenient
because of the extra zoom forcing you to
move back
further to get the subject in frame so
because
of all of that i found myself always
just using the regular wide camera
for portrait shots and it shouldn't be
like that
and even for daytime photos i struggle
to find an
improvement in quality between the 12
pro's maximum 10x
zoom and the 12 pro max's 12x zoom
now it's not just the telephoto lens
that's different on the pro max
apple also made a huge deal about the
sensor
on the wide camera being 47
larger than on the pro so this brings us
into problem number five apple said that
the pro max
gives you 87 better low-light photos
but when i compared them i honestly
didn't see
that big of a difference and for night
mode shots
it does help but it's not that big of a
deal
the biggest difference i noticed was
that night mode shots
take a shorter amount of time to take
the photo
which is very convenient since you don't
have to wait as long
but in terms of quality it was hard to
tell a difference
now when you're taking photos with the
wide camera during the daytime
it is extremely difficult to notice any
difference at all
on top of that the pro max gets the new
sensor shift
optical stabilization which does an
excellent job
but the 12 pro also does a great job of
stabilization
into the average person they probably
wouldn't notice the difference
taking it even further we've noticed
that the pro max is wide camera
is much worse in terms of the minimum
focusing distance
the regular pro can focus much closer to
the subject
and because of that the bokeh in the
background
actually looks bigger for macro shots
now problem number six is one that
really really annoys me and that is lens
flare
while shooting photos or videos at night
check out this video recorded on the 12
pro max
as you can see the lights are reflecting
off of the lens
itself and causing really bad flaring
this is extremely distracting when
trying to record a video of lights like
this
or maybe something like a christmas
light show an
1100 iphone shouldn't be having
this big of a problem now this also
happens for photos
like this one of my son in front of the
fireplace
there is a really distracting flare from
the fire that's positioned
right in front of him and it kind of
ruins the photo
this is actually a much bigger issue on
the 12 pro max specifically
because the camera lenses are much
larger and the lens glass itself
sticks out further than the exterior
metal rings
which causes light to reflect off of
them
so in this comparison you can see how
the pro-max
is worse than the other models so it's
definitely been causing problems
over the past month moving on to problem
number seven it has to do
with max safe and max safe accessories
when we first got the max safe wallet
and tested it out on the iphone 12 pro
it worked pretty well and we didn't
really notice much issues with it being
bumped out of place
or falling off when putting it into your
pocket however
with the 12 pro max the wallet is
noticeably worse
and i think it's because there is extra
dead space on the back of the iphone
so there's more room for it to move
around and get knocked out of place
we actually confirmed that theory by
using the wallet with the iphone 12 mini
where the edges of the wallet are
perfectly flush with the sides of the
mini
and because of that it's extremely hard
to accidentally bump the wallet out of
place
because your hand is supporting it from
the other side
so the wallet experience is by far the
worst
on the pro max which is very
disappointing now the magsafe problems
don't end there
apple's new mac save charger is problem
number eight
for forty dollars it's simply not worth
it at
all yes it's convenient that it attaches
magnetically
but the charging speed is unbearably
slow
max made a crazy detail charging
comparison video
and he found that even with the new 20
watt usbc charging brick
max safe was only 15 minutes faster
than the old 5 watt charging brick when
charging from zero to 100 percent
yes it was quite a bit faster in the
beginning of the test
but when you hear 15 watt max say fast
charging
you'd expect it to be just a little bit
slower than the 20 watt cable charging
but that ended up finishing the test a
full hour sooner
than maxsafe so in my personal opinion
the magsafe charger is a problem because
it charges
way slower than apple is leading people
to believe now for mistake number nine
it has to do with overheating the new
iphone 12s come with the latest
a14 bionic chip which is made using
tsmc's
brand new 5 nanometer technology which
is super efficient
however max was doing some call of duty
mobile gaming
in a very bright barber shop so the
display brightness automatically
brightened up and he noticed that after
just 10 minutes
the display dimmed because of
overheating
this is an issue because the five
nanometer chip is supposed to be more
efficient
and it's supposed to run more cool so we
thought that we'd no longer have these
overheating issues ever again
but that's not the case other phone
manufacturers like samsung have been
implementing cooling solutions
like a built-in vapor chamber to reduce
overheating problems but apple doesn't
seem to care
so it's a bit annoying when you have to
deal with these issues
on such an expensive flagship phone and
finally
let's get into problem number 10. the
iphone 12 pro max
is still using the lightning port and
we're honestly getting a bit sick of it
while every other device on the market
is moving over to the usb-c
port apple refuses to switch if the
iphone had a usb-c
port everything from file transfers to
charging
would be much more convenient i'd love
to be able to grab my macbook charging
cable
and quickly charge up my iphone but i
can't
because it uses lightning and now even
the ipad air 4
uses usbc but not the iphone
which is starting to get very annoying
because we now know
just how much better usbc is than
lightning
in basically every way so with all of
those 10 problems out of the way
my final conclusion or advice is that if
you are thinking about going for the 12
pro max
model maybe for the extra camera
improvements
it's really not worth it in reality the
camera differences weren't that big
so if you were thinking about getting
the regular 6.1 inch 12 pro model
go for it so there you guys have it that
was our top 10 problems with the iphone
12 pro max after a full month of use
so if you agree or disagree with any of
those
please comment your thoughts down below
and click the circle above to subscribe
for our full iphone 12 pro max review
that's coming very soon
thank you guys for watching and we'll
see you in the next video